The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
ZEYNEB MAGAVI: The more
we can measure volume,
the more we'll be able to follow
the recent law we got passed
that says they have to
prioritize the highest
volume for climate hazard.
So that's a new law.
They never got to do it, so
now they need the information,
and they've never
gotten [INAUDIBLE]
cared about explosion risk.
The president of Eversource
Gas in the meeting recently, he
was very talkative,
and he started
talking about how
there's new research
and development in natural gas
restructure in the US period.
They don't do it.
No one else does it-- that
they go to France, England,
and Germany, because they
invest in R&D for this field,
and they find out
what's going on.
And they're way ahead of us.
They're way ahead
of us over there,
which was really
interesting to me to hear.
And they, in that
room, there was
no doubt they have no
idea what the problem is.
They don't measure it.
They don't document it.
And from what we
can tell so far,
there's no acceptable
norm on how to measure it.
So there is these two really
kind of kludgy methods to me,
and then there's--
I mean, we're trying to
invent a method that's
actually the utilities
can go out and do.
Because the guys on the
ground have to do it.
DAVID OLIVER: You know
what's kind of funny--
ZEYNEB MAGAVI: Yeah?
DAVID OLIVER: --is
that you can find it
when it's, you know, sort of
naturally occurring and worth
something to us, but we
can't find it when it's
going through our own system.
It's sad.
And it's three feet
below the surface.
ZEYNEB MAGAVI: Piece
of data on volume--
did you tell them about
the Harvard study?
AUDREY SCHULMAN:
Yeah, I did earlier.
So we know how much there is
from the top down from the,
you know--
in the atmosphere, we know
how much gas there is,
but we don't know where the
most-- you know, that 5%--
5% to 7% of the
worst gas leaks are.
So this is-- we have to
come up with a method to--
when they're about
to repair the leak--
after they've pinpointed what
they think is a high-volume
leak, how do we--
SPEAKER 1: Verify that
that's a [INAUDIBLE]
SPEAKER 2: Do we have on that
global thing, gas in, gas out?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
Over time, by--
ZEYNEB MAGAVI: It doesn't
match the outside.
SPEAKER 2: Well, of
course it shouldn't.
Leakage is def-- but how is
that changing all the time?
AUDREY SCHULMAN: So the
utilities have crappy data.
They have crappy meters.
They have crappy everything.
So they have no-- so your meter
at your house is not a very
good, you know,
temperature changes--
SPEAKER 2: It's
right, plus or minus
x, where x is too big a number.
AUDREY SCHULMAN: Yeah, the
margin of error is huge.
What this is-- just
to give the idea
that we've come up
with after months
of working with the utilities
and ripping information out
of them is to use these
two instruments when
they-- so they pinpointed--
so this is that point
that they pinpointed the
high volume-- what they think
is a high-volume leak.
And in order to do that, they
drill holes in the streets.
So they found using this
instrument and another one--
they found that there's
gas in the area.
And they stuck this, with a
probe on it, into the soil,
and they found sort of the leak
extent, the area in the ground
that has a lot of gas in it.
And then they drill
holes in the streets.
So maybe, let's say, it
goes from 21 Smith street
to 25 Smith street,
and then they
drill holes in the street
along there and use this again.
They put the probe
in each of the holes
in the street over the pipe.
Should I draw a picture?
Does this--
SPEAKER 3: They don't drill into
the pipe-- just over the pipe.
AUDREY SCHULMAN: Over the pipe.
And they stick this probe
in and find out where
the highest percent of gas is.
DAVID OLIVER: So they're working
with a map of the pipes, right?
ZEYNEB MAGAVI: They usually have
a printed out, like, sketchy
little map with a line,
and it's approximate.
I've watched them do it.
It's close.
They kind of know
where their pipe is.
AUDREY SCHULMAN: They
drill holes in the street.
They take this thing-- and
stick the probe in those holes
and find out where the
highest gas is-- the highest
percentage of gas is.
And so, then they
excavate at that point,
because they assume the
leak was right there.
SPEAKER 3: And they
admitted how often they're
right when they do that?
AUDREY SCHULMAN: They do
not share any information
at all of any kind.
SPEAKER 3: All right,
the latest theory--
AUDREY SCHULMAN: They believe
this method works very well,
but anybody who's
looked at streets,
you'll see lots of,
like patches, right,
when at any time, they--
so sometimes they screw up.
How often?
We don't know.
SPEAKER 2: Go look at
the [INAUDIBLE] wells.
Just go look at it.
They just repainted
it, and it's already--
AUDREY SCHULMAN: So
if they're confused.
If say, this is
100%, this is 100%,
this is 100%, they
don't where the leak is,
what they do is they use this.
They stick that in down
into the hole that they've--
one of these holes.
They put a compressor
in this side,
and they open this valve--
so, already, I
guess it is open--
so that 80 pounds per
square inch of air
is being blown across here.
This is a hollow tube, so it
sucks air up really quickly.
And this plunger
gets pushed down,
so that it's sealed
to the street.
Does that makes sense?
SPEAKER 3: Mhm.
AUDREY SCHULMAN: So air
is being pulled out,
you know, really quickly.
It's a vacuum-- drags all
the gas out of the ground,
and that way, they
vacuum all the gas out
from this entire area.
And then they use the
CGI again to this thing
to see where the gas is
coming back up fastest,
and that's where they
excavate to fix the leak.
Does that make sense?
SPEAKER 3: Yes, I get it.
AUDREY SCHULMAN:
So we want to use
this tool in a different way
to find how big the leak is.
So instead, once
they pin the leak--
once they found the leak, we
want to take this and put it
in the ground.
Again, attach a regulate--
a compressor here,
blow the air out, and put a
combustible gas indicator here
to see what the percentage
is of gas coming out of it.
By doing that, we will know how
much the flow-through, right--
because it's 80 pounds per
square inch coming out of here,
and we'll know the
percentage of gas.
And using that, we can get
a rough idea of how much,
how big the leak is, how
much gas is coming out
and how quickly.
Does that make sense?
SPEAKER 4: [INAUDIBLE]
AUDREY SCHULMAN:
This is a purger.
We only learned
about it on Friday.
I am so excited to have it here.
SPEAKER 5: It's
called a diffuser.
AUDREY SCHULMAN: Diffuser.
DAVID OLIVER: The message
that you described
sounds like it will
tell you roughly
how much gas was trapped in the
area that you were evacuating,
which might not be adjacent
to the leak-- it could travel
and then get trapped.
AUDREY SCHULMAN: So you have
to wait for a steady state
reading.
DAVID OLIVER: True.
AUDREY SCHULMAN: So
the gas will pocket up
underneath the pavement,
because gas is lighter than air.
And so, you will get
a sort of pool of gas
right up against the pavement,
and for the first few minutes,
you're going to pull
out that residual--
SPEAKER 2: So don't you also
[INAUDIBLE] nature of that
substance--
sand, clay, dirt.
AUDREY SCHULMAN: Aha, yes.
Whether it's wet, whether
it's dry, and yes,
the temperature is--
SPEAKER 2: --what the nature
is of that diffusing material.
AUDREY SCHULMAN: To get an exact
measurement, yes, we would.
But the high-volume leaks
are 10 times bigger--
more bigger than that the
low-volume leaks, so got to--
SPEAKER 2: So that
shouldn't matter --
AUDREY SCHULMAN: So you've
got an order of magnitude
difference, so all that
stuff hopefully will be--
I mean, we'll have to find out.
But I think this
method will work enough
to get us in the ball
field, so that we can say,
high volume, not
high volume, higher--
you know, we just want
to bucket the leaks,
basically, categorize them.
DAVID OLIVER: I got a question.
So they're fixing--
they're trying
to fix what will be categorized
as high-volume, right?
They're not trying to fix
everything that they find,
right?
AUDREY SCHULMAN:
Right, this law that
got passed is simply to
fix the high-volume leaks.
DAVID OLIVER: Yeah.
But, you know, when they go
and they do their testing,
and they get a
series of readings,
they basically guess
where they think
the high volume
is, fix that joint,
and then they forget about
what's 12 feet that way
and 12 feet that way.
AUDREY SCHULMAN: Yes.
You mean there could
be another leak?
Is that what you're--
DAVID OLIVER: Well, sure.
I mean, in the case of
they picked the wrong one,
and there's still a
high-volume leak there--
and it's that that doesn't
get found until maybe they
come back to the same spot.
SPEAKER 2: Well, back up.
How do they determine?
Is there another step once
they picked the highest volume
and dug to the ground?
I've watched them--
a physical test
of identifying a real leak--
you know, pipe, gas spewing out
at the actual leak
once it's uncovered.
Is that a standard
process, or do they--
to your own point, there
may only be one leak.
There's a physical
identification of the leak
once they've decided
to take action.
AUDREY SCHULMAN: Yes.
But we can--
SPEAKER 2: There could
be five or six of them.
AUDREY SCHULMAN: We have
to assume they somewhat
know their job, so they can--
they'll find the leak,
and they'll fix it.
And afterwards--
and a lot of these
might be weak complexes,
which means many leaks
along the way in which case
the whole area, that 21 to 25
Smith street is a
leak complex, and they
have to fix all those leaks.
So they should use this method
to measure the emissions off
of each one of those
sub-leaks and then add them up
into one high-volume leak.
So the utilities
use the word leak
in a very different
way than we do,
which is like leak location.
So then we will be adding
up all the emissions, which
means that this method
should not suck the gas out
of more than one leak.
Or if it does, we will
have to figure out how to--
DAVID OLIVER: Yeah,
I think it might.
I would imagine that if
you have gas pooling,
or you have multiple
leaks, there's
going to be some
connection between them?
AUDREY SCHULMAN: Yeah.
DAVID OLIVER: So if
you create a volume--
a vacuum here, it's going to
start pulling from the other.
AUDREY SCHULMAN: Yeah.
So one of the things
we possibly can do
is there's going to be somewhere
it's just going to be one leak,
and using that data,
we can figure out
what the average leak is.
And therefore, when we have a
leak location, a leak complex,
we can hopefully
figure out how much
overage there is--
how much excess gas
we're pulling in
from the others.
Yeah, so the things
I think we need--
I think we need two things.
One is some sort of
regulator to step this down,
so the compressor
coming in at 80 PSI in.
ZEYNEB MAGAVI: Well, the other
thing is this says 80 PSI,
but the guys in the truck
say their compressor is 120.
AUDREY SCHULMAN: Yeah.
So some sort of--
DAVID OLIVER: [INAUDIBLE] crank
it up all the way up though.
ZEYNEB MAGAVI: And so,
how do we make sure what--
because if we don't
know pressure.
AUDREY SCHULMAN: If we don't
have the known rate of speed
across here, the data's crap.
And we also don't want to vacuum
up higher than the operating
pressure of the pipe.
So the pipe--
DAVID OLIVER:
Because then you'll
just draw it out of the pipe?
AUDREY SCHULMAN: Right.
And it will be
increasing the leak,
and it will be
crappy data again.
Does that make sense?
ZEYNEB MAGAVI: Yeah.
AUDREY SCHULMAN:
So these pipes can
be anywhere from 0.5, that
we're going to be working with,
to 60 PSI, so 120 times--
so that's a difficult
problem on its own.
So we need some
sort of regulator
that will not
increase-- you know,
that probably is
going to at 0.5 PSI,
so we have to step
this down enormously.
So that's one problem, and
I don't know if that's true.
So I am not a scientist,
so anybody who wants to--
DAVID OLIVER: Yeah,
I mean, putting
80 PSI on that
doesn't mean you're
going to create an 80 PSI--
a negative 80 PSI
vacuum, but there
is a correlation [INAUDIBLE]
AUDREY SCHULMAN: OK, so
what's the regulator here?
How far do we have
to step it down?
What regulator, I
need the doohickey
that goes here to be able to
step it down in a correct--
you know, in a way
that it will not--
ZEYNEB MAGAVI: We
need to control this--
AUDREY SCHULMAN: Yeah, and
preferably just one setting,
because these guys are going to
be like, you just turn it on.
Just do it.
You know, I got to go for lunch.
DAVID OLIVER: Without
modifying this?
AUDREY SCHULMAN: Yes,
without modifying it.
So it's going to be
another doohickey.
They're going to take this off,
put the other doohickey in,
and crank it on.
DAVID OLIVER: Because if
they're-- yeah, if they're--
if you measure PSI
here, then you're
getting sort of a direct
reading of the vacuum
that you're creating, right?
AUDREY SCHULMAN: Yeah.
So there is this
valve, but we don't
know if this valve is working.
DAVID OLIVER: Yeah.
But, I mean, if you take the
80 PSI that you're putting in,
you can calculate what that
vacuum should be, so, you know,
that could be simply a
lookup chart or something
like that for them.
AUDREY SCHULMAN:
Yeah, we got have it--
you know, the whole thing is
to make it so simple they just
write down one number in
the end-- error-proof,
and you got to imagine.
You've seen the contractors
out there, right?
This is not of their interest.
They are doing this
unwillingly, so we
have to come up with a super,
super simple method that
can just bucket the leaks.
ZEYNEB MAGAVI: So
there seem to be
two techniques in the literature
for volume measurement of gas.
One is the chamber method, which
is a closed sample and measured
over time to get flow
rate, and the other one
is the flow rate, which is
the rate of air movement--
you know the speed
of air movement,
and then you take
one point sample.
So the idea of
this, we're actually
going to be doing
the chamber method
on the leaks in the street.
It's error proof.
And the idea of this is to try
to get the flow-rate method
measurement, so maybe we will
also take some capsules that--
AUDREY SCHULMAN: They're
not going to go for it.
ZEYNEB MAGAVI: They're
very concerned.
They're very risk-averse.
They're very concerned
about any capturing of gas.
AUDREY SCHULMAN: I
meant I can't tell you
how unusual it is that they
are willing to do this.
This alone is a
stunning step forward.
DAVID OLIVER: Are these guys
employees of the utility
companies or subcontractors?
AUDREY SCHULMAN: Probably both.
DAVID OLIVER: OK.
Is there a possibility of
kind of developing somebody--
I mean, developing a core
of trained professionals who
would then contract with the
utility companies who do this?
AUDREY SCHULMAN: So we're going
to do a training basically
with the utilities to teach
them how to do the technique,
but first we need to come
up with the exact technique.
And that's like in three
weeks, so we're on a deadline.
ZEYNEB MAGAVI: And we're
trying to figure out a way
to incentivize it for the guys.
We've been talking to
them, and actually they're
not all the same age.
There's a wide array.
Some of them are actually pretty
interested, so to be fair.
It seems like we have three
different ideas so far.
Does that make sense?
We have the one we
just said at sensor--
what are we calling this
part of the doohickey?
Inlet.
DAVID OLIVER: Inlet--
ZEYNEB MAGAVI: --into inlet two.
Two is no sensor used pressure
to pressure, and 3 is attach--
SPEAKER 2:
Sensor-dependent output.
ZEYNEB MAGAVI:
--sensor to output.
OK, so each of these
definitely have pros and cons.
That's where we're at, right?
SPEAKER 2: Yeah.
DAVID OLIVER: Number
two is also doing
the sort of baseline
measurements, correct?
SPEAKER 2: Yeah,
that's the pros,
and we don't know if two works.
I would argue that
if two works, that
meets your operational issues
better than anything else,
because you--
all you're asking
them is to read
this meter That's the change
in process, basically.
DAVID OLIVER: The
good thing about one
is that they see something that
may alarm them, as opposed to--
well, actually, if they do
enough for the calculations,
and they may see the
pressure reading, and say,
oh, something's wrong.
But if they see something
new that says, ooh, problem.
SPEAKER 2: Yeah, no,
I'm with you, but--
DAVID OLIVER: The
red light goes on.
ZEYNEB MAGAVI: Should we go
through a new pros and cons?
SPEAKER 2: It might
be worthwhile.
ZEYNEB MAGAVI: Or is
this the kind of thing
where maybe we should just
test all of the options.
Like, work them out.
Break into a group
and work out what
we would need to do to test it.
DAVID OLIVER: Or,
you know, you said
the pressure variation in
the pipes is 0.5 PSI to--
ZEYNEB MAGAVI: To 60 PSI.
DAVID OLIVER: --to 60, jeese.
ZEYNEB MAGAVI: And
that's just the pipes
that we need them working on.
DAVID OLIVER: Don't
be standard or OK.
ZEYNEB MAGAVI: So that's
one of the reasons why
this is a hard problem.
That's why I want
to step this down,
so that we don't
ever, like, pull
the gas out of the pipe faster
than the leak would normally
be.
AUDREY SCHULMAN: So should
we break into groups
to look at these
three possible methods
and sort of come up with
some of the questions,
the experiments
that need to happen,
the products associated?
ZEYNEB MAGAVI: A
next-steps list?
AUDREY SCHULMAN: Yeah.
DAVID OLIVER: First of
all, they can control that.
They can control
the input pressure,
so they can control
the pressure drawn,
and there is ton of
resistance in the soil.
So in order to do that, you
would have to really crank up
the pressurized--
SPEAKER 2: I don't know.
I'm just--
DAVID OLIVER: I
don't-- you know--
SPEAKER 2: I don't know if I'm
even in the right ballpark.
DAVID OLIVER: I think there is
so much resistance in the soil.
SPEAKER 2: If there's enough
resistance, it's not a crack,
and then I don't care.
But if it is, if it's close--
DAVID OLIVER: Maybe
it's dried sand.
The other thing that's going
to happen is where you have
a leak, you're normally going to
have some diffusion in the soil
so they're going to be finding
wherever their path of least
resistance is, but then you
introduce a vacuum where
it's-- you're going to want
to draw the gas towards that?
Whether the leak is
here, or it's over there.
ZEYNEB MAGAVI: Right.
So maybe the distance between
the leak and our drill hole
doesn't matter,
and maybe it does.
Sorry, if I made it--
SPEAKER 2: What is clear about
this is this all eminently
testable.
ZEYNEB MAGAVI: Yes.
SPEAKER 2: This is all
experimental research
and try it and--
but it doesn't sound
like you have [INAUDIBLE]
DAVID OLIVER: So to do these--
SPEAKER 2: That's a plus.
AUDREY SCHULMAN: So there
are, like, the Gas Technology
Institute that's [INAUDIBLE] and
there's the Montreal Research
Institute?
ZEYNEB MAGAVI: And they have
a buried pipe in the ground.
You can turn the valve flow.
AUDREY SCHULMAN:
But that costs money
to do that in place
and test things.
Whereas, you know, a
small non-profit --.